I was watching jeopardy the other night
and I thinks I think that Alex Trebek is
starting to lose it a little bit just
let's try the sonnet for 400 Skrillex
whose name is Yiddish for toxic pig skin
became deaf in his right ear while
probing the human embryo with the gas
powered congresswoman sidekicks for
2,000 whoops
Bruce Willis but dial my mother-in-law
saying bring over a young mother and go
outside and dig up some patties what is
Monsanto currently the top ten baby
names for Jewish girls include inchworm
happy nuts
floozy puss caterpillar smokes brown
sugar and desert dweller and that was
the FIFA Women's World Cup with dr. Troy
Hugh Jackman is a hairy man with one
sack like body cavity that looks like an
older dog with thick fur who was put to
sleep from making a fool of himself
Britain's go again
Disney sidekicks for 400 plays oh my god
a self-absorbed carpets soaking yoga
instructors squeezed out a humorously
small sausage equivalent to one sixtieth
of a belly button
Brits what are can't be more specific
what are aluminum cans get more specific
what are beer cans be more specific what
are aluminum beer can't be more specific
better
[Applause]
hello you seem to be having a good time
here today hello uh hello mr. Trebek
obviously we're all huge fans of your
show we were I was doing that to just
have a little bit of fun that's okay I'm
not upset I'm a big guy I can look after
myself but I'm here for another reason
I'm worried about you
I've been watching some of your
monologues lately and I'm concerned I
think you are starting to lose it take a
look and see if you don't agree Miami
Police announced they're releasing a
video of Justin Bieber urinating in his
jail cell yeah yeah it was the first
time toddlers were able to plant their
crack pipes right there in the top of
another dog's butt but it backfired cos
Bieber grandma successfully sent a
monkey hooker into space
[Applause]
okay I guess I guess we're even now
we're even
all right I'll agree to that we are even
but before I go I just want to leave you
with one more thought the next time you
consider taking a person's words out of
context and manipulating all of that to
make them look foolish I want you to
think about this the ex-president of
Ukraine james van der beek often
massages weasels in order to extract
this foul-smelling waxy secretion that
has bridge engineers all over the world
screaming
[Applause]
[Music]
sit back ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]